What's up wise?
Crack,
jared.
Again,
Jurassic world,
fallen kingdom has been absolutely
obliterated by critics and audiences
alike.
Calling out it's unfunny character's
lack of originality and worst of all,
the unforgivable sin of not enough cif
gold flute.
Now there's a lot to be said about how
the latest Jurassic movies haven't
amazed us in the same way that
Spielberg's 1993 original did,
but at least Jurassic world seemed
somewhat aware of its inherent
shortcomings.
Let's be honest,
no one's impressed by a dinosaur,
but the Jurassic world follow up.
Falling Kingdom shows how far the
franchise has fallen on paper,
though it actually seems to have
something going for it because unlike
it's 2015 predecessor,
the movie actually tries to develop the
underlying moral question of the
original.
It moves from,
should dinosaurs be brought back to life
too?
Should we consciously let dinosaurs go
extinct again?
No one can deny that fallen kingdom
looks absolutely stunning at times,
but despite the magicians of dollars
thrown at the special effects budget,
the movie is still so boring.
So why aren't we more immersed than
ever?
Well,
let's find out in this wise crack
condition on Jurassic world,
fallen kingdom.
What went wrong?
And spoilers ahead if anyone cares.
Let's briefly recap.
For those of you who've already left
this movie go extinct in their minds
after the destruction of Jurassic world
at the closet,
the in dominous rex,
the dinosaurs are left to run the island
freely once more.
However,
fast forward three years and a volcano
on the island is about to blast little
foot and ducky into extinction once
again.
Oh and then claire,
don't lie,
you forgot their names too.
Don't want this to happen.
And join a rescue team in an effort to
save as many of the species as they can.
So the stage is set presenting us with
perhaps the most action packed high
stakes situation and Jurassic Park
history while simultaneously evoking the
main ethical and moral questions that
made the original.
So beloved,
should we take responsibility for our
own creations and save the dinosaurs
from their second extinction?
Or should we bow down to mother nature
and let the volcano deal with our
incompetence once and for all?
So let's see what we got here.
Developing themes from the original
check,
sweet digital effects and action check.
Everyone's favorite killing machine
check.
So what could possibly go wrong?
Life finds a way by contrast,
the original Jurassic Park came out 25
whole years ago in a time when CGI was
still in its infancy.
So it shouldn't surprise anyone that the
handful of computerized dinosaurs
featured in the original aren't exactly
up to par with today's CGI.
So why is it then that the age action
sequences in Jurassic Park still feel
more engaging and memorable than the
visually superior set pieces have fallen
kingdom?
To answer this question,
we need to go back to the man who
started at all Steven Spielberg and his
own words.
Spielberg avoided making just another
monster movie and this was not going to
be a genre of horror science fiction
fantasy.
He didn't want Jurassic Park to revolve
around scary monsters chasing after
helpless one dimensional characters and
said he wanted the film to focus on the
journey of a group of relatable
characters who have to deal with the
reality that dinosaurs have been
suddenly brought back to life.
For Spielberg,
the original drastic park was a human
story,
not date dinosaurs eating people's
story.
It's not just about the visual spectacle
of witnessing a man getting eaten off
the toilet by a dinosaur,
but the emotional journeys of the
characters and it's with this knowledge
in mind,
don't be uncover why this is infinitely
less yon inducing.
Then this insanity take for instance the
now iconic t-rex scene in Jurassic Park,
just as our protagonists are passing by
the enclosure of the king of all
dinosaurs,
the park's power grid is suddenly turned
off leaving the mighty rex free to go
wherever she pleases.
The biggest man eating animal in the
world escapes and our protagonists are
the first pray to cross her path.
What follows is a roughly six minute
action suspense sequence in which our
protagonist try their best.
Not to.
Getty seems pretty straightforward,
right?
Well,
yes and no.
Even though the characters trying to
survive is what is literally happening
on the screen.
It's what's going on under the surface
that matters from a story perspective
isn't as much about the introduction of
the t rex as it is about the protagonist
Dr.
Alan Grant learning to become a father
at the beginning of the film,
we're introduced to the idea that Dr.
Grant is not exactly the kind of guy who
lets his nephew when at super smash
brothers.
In fact,
Spielberg really tries to hammer home
that grant doesn't like kids and would
rather remain obsessed with the dead
past.
Then thinking about creating life in the
future,
you want to have one of those.
We're also briefly notified that Hammons
daughter of the mom of these two kids is
going through a divorce and you telling
me that Hannah Kinney,
have you gone in to see me?
He had to leave early.
He wants to be with these daughters.
She's getting a divorce.
I understand that.
So even though we're all just anxiously
waiting to see newman gets skeeted on by
a Deloft,
the source,
the stage is set for the underlying
theme of the movie family.
Let's head back to that pivotal scene.
Donald,
the only adult in the car with the kids
suddenly feels his breakfast Burrito
twirling around in his bowels and
decides to dip out and head to the
nearest bathroom.
The kids having been abandoned by yet
another male authority figure are alone
and panicking.
Dr.
Grant immediately realizes he has to
make a decision.
He can either remain still and decrease
his chances of getting eaten or act in a
selfless,
somewhat fatherly manner.
Alan,
one repression of father instincts zero.
It's moments like this that elevate the
action from Amir.
Will they survive to how will the
characters grow as they try to survive?
So when good old rexy breaks through her
own glass ceiling at the start of a
sequence,
it's not just mere spectacle,
it's action in service of character
growth and theme.
It engages us not just because it looks
cool,
but because we can relate to the story
on a personal level.
Jurassic world,
fallen kingdom,
on the other hand,
has almost none of this.
Sure.
At the start of the story were
reintroduced to be moral and ethical
questions surrounding the survival or
demise of the dinosaurs on the island.
Do dinosaurs deserve the same
protections given to other endangered
species or should they be left to die?
But we learn next to nothing about the
internal lives of the protagonists.
So even though its main action set piece
might be visually far more impressive
than the t rex scene without this
underlying layer,
what you see is what you get Chris Pratt
running away from dinosaurs and lava.
It might be a feast for the eyes,
but it starves us emotionally.
Let's look at another example from the
original right after the t rex breakout
scene,
Alan has to try and save timmy who still
trapped in this car.
Unfortunately for them,
this tree can't hold the cars weight and
it's about the drop and crush our
protagonists to death in fallen kingdom.
We see a similar action sequence unfold
when Claire and Franklin have to climb a
ladder to escape a hungry dinosaur whose
only barely being held back by a
dripping wall of lava.
It doesn't seem too different from the
falling car setup,
right?
Well,
the difference here is that this moment,
10 drastic park isn't just a random
moment for the sake of suspense,
but that it again serves to develop the
theme of the story.
Just like can you ask,
she asked.
His Dad is affiliate treatments.
Alan is again forced into a position in
which he has to act as a father in order
to save timmies life,
and even the climax of the sequence with
Alan and timmy miraculously surviving
the car,
falling down on them serves a purpose
instead of just being a copout cliche to
trick the audience into thinking that
the characters have died on the tree.
This moment is used to show the
metaphorical rebirth of Allen like a
dinosaur from an egg.
He's no longer the dinosaur obsessed
child diverse man he once was,
but instead has embraced the possibility
of being a future father.
Now that's an action scene packed with
meaning and yeah,
you probably guessed it.
Falling Kingdom has nothing like this,
like Alan and Timmy Clare and Franklin
also barely escaped their deaths in the
nick of time.
But that's all there is to it.
Nothing about the characters or their
relationship has changed.
And so there's no meaning to it beyond
survival.
So what could have been a visualization
of their inner growth ends up being
another vapid spectacle since the
characters remained virtually the same.
So the reason why this action scenes
still grabs us 25 years after its
inception is not just because it first
introduced us to the t rex,
but because of how it uses action in
service of the underlying story,
it tells two stories at the same time.
One that excites us and add suspense and
one that people can truly relate to.
Combine the two and you have an action
sequence that engages audiences across
time,
no matter how prehistoric it's visuals,
all the pieces were there to make a
thoroughly enjoyable and memorable film,
perhaps equaling or even surpassing the
original a film with the same sort of
engaging emotional subtext as the
original combined with the advancement
in digital effects could have made for
something truly special.
And yes,
I'm sure some people had a blast
watching Chris Pratt runaway from
dinosaurs and giant melting rocks,
but will these scene still truly live on
in the minds of those same people 25
years from now?
Needless to say,
we have doubts,
at least Trev row in Bayona made sure
that the series wouldn't evolve further
into a mindless monster movie by
repeating the same mistake Spielberg
made in the lost world.
Oh,
if you're sad that all the real
dinosaurs went the way the fidget
spinner don't be,
there's actually plenty of prehistoric
monsters that's still roam the earth.
And to the best of my knowledge,
none of them will go all newman on you.
Take,
for example,
the great salamander,
who for the past 160 million years has
remained relatively unchanged,
and there is a version of it that's so
nasty that early American settlers named
it after health fun.
But to learn all about that,
you got to check out the newest video
from animal logic.
If you love learning about the amazing
animals we share the planet with,
and I really think you're gonna like
animal logic,
Danielle combines her explanatory powers
with her scientific illustrations to
teach you everything you ever wanted to
know about animals from the antelope
that looked like they're straight out of
star wars.
Two wasps that I honestly never want to
see in my life.
They're disgusting.
If you love animals as much as I do,
click here to check out animal logic.
Thanks for watching guys.
Peace.